hi in this video I'm going to derive
Michaelis Menten equation so let's start
with our enzyme substitute reaction we
have enzyme plus substrate it would form
our enzyme substrate complex and then it
would form enzyme plus product so for
this forward strip that the rest rate
constant of this step is k1 and for this
reverse step we would denote it as K
minus 1 and for this second step it
would be k2 and now we have to do a
assumption called as steady state
assumption so what is the steady state
assumption so if we draw a graph in
which in the x-axis we would plot time
and in the y-axis we would put
concentration then what would happen
with the increase of time with the
increase in time the substrate
concentration would go gradually down
whereas the increase of time the product
concentration would increase so this is
the product concentration and this is
the substrate concentration and in the
meanwhile the concentration of the
enzyme and substrate complex the es
complex would first increase and then it
would reach a steady state or we can say
it could reach a plateau so from this
particular assumption our assumption
would be the rate of formation of enzyme
substrate complex or es or rate of
breakdown is almost constant so as it is
constant then rate of change of enzyme
substrate cons
substrate complex with respect to time
and
des DT it would be zero so this
particular is our steady state
assumption and now from this Michaelis
Menten equation we would try to find the
rate equations
so first let's say we were talking about
formation so the rate of formation of es
so the rate of formation of e from the
rate of formation of es we can write the
equation like the concentration of es is
equal to k1 times concentration of
enzyme and concentration of substrate
and then we would write the breakdown of
rate of breakdown of es and the
breakdown of enzyme substrate complex
here we would get so this is actually
rate of formation and rate of breakdown
is actually K minus 1 into es because we
have to consider the backward direction
and it's also breaking down to form give
out the product and enzyme so we have to
consider the k2 into yes so as per our
steady state assumption rate of
formation is exactly equal to rate of
breakdown so we would equate these two
things so our rate of formation of es in
then substrate complex is actually equal
to rate of breakdown of enzyme substrate
complex so this is actually equal so now
if we do our maths then what we would
find these total of enzyme this would be
actually
enzyme total - these enzyme substrate
complex and the list of the equation
would be same and now if we do again in
the step and rearrange all these thing
we would end up getting k1 ET into
substrate concentration equal to es and
if we take common in all these things
then we would find K minus 1 plus k2 if
we do the maths we would get these thing
and if we divide this thing with k1 over
here then we would get ET into substrate
concentration which is actually equal to
es into plus K minus 1 plus k2 by k1 so
these whole term is actually known as km
the Michaelis Menten constant and these
particular term is known as km so now
you would write the equation as equal to
es substrate concentration plus km so
now we have in our hand that is equal to
enzyme total enzyme concentration into
substrate concentration divided by
substrate concentration plus our
Michaelis Menten constant now from our
discussions we can see that rate of
product formation rate of product
formation with respect to time is
actually considered as velocity of the
enzyme reaction and rate of product
formation is solely dependent upon the
of breakdown of enzyme-substrate contra
the enzyme-substrate complex
so that is why rate of change the rate
of change of appearance of the product
would be actually equal to k2 into yes
now if we get back to our equation if we
multiply both sides with k2 both side we
are multiplying with k2 so we are
getting somewhat like this and this k2
yes it is actually our velocity of
enzymatic wrap reaction and now the
particular quantity K 2 into ET is
considered as v-max so it is the
velocity of the enzyme when all the
active sites are saturated by the
product so it's a maximal velocity of
the enzyme so what would happen v-0 is
equal to v-max into substrate
concentration divided by a substrate +
km so this particular equation is known
as Michaelis Menten equation now what we
do we would try to plot a graph or this
Michaelis Menten equation so here we are
plotting a graph in the x axis we have
the substrate concentration and in the y
axis we have velocity of enzyme action
so what would happen first when the
substrate concentration is low the
velocity of the enzyme reaction and the
substrate concentration would show a
linear relationship that means that
means with increase of the substrate the
velocity of enzyme reaction would
gradually increase but after a certain
concentration of the substrate when the
substrate concentration would be pretty
high then with the increase of the
substrate the velocity of the enzyme
reaction doesn't change much so there is
actually it reached a plateau so it
reached a plateau so here what would
happen if we try to draw the scenario
then here if it is our enzyme then there
are not much substrate but here what
happens and all the enzymes are not
saturated here enzymes are and
substrates are in a balanced manner but
here in this condition what happens all
our enzymes are fully saturated by the
substrate plus we have extra substrate
so if we increase more and more
substrate it won't increase the velocity
because all the enzymes over at this
condition at this higher substrate
concentration are saturating the enzyme
enzymes active site so no matter how
much we increase the substrate
concentration the velocity of the enzyme
reaction would no more increase so at
this point we would say it had reached a
maximum velocity so this is called v-max
and now we would define our substrate
game the Michaelis Menten concentration
the Michaelis Menten constant actually
so game eco is actually the substrate
concentration so game would be on the x
axis substrate concentration at which
the velocity of the enzyme reaction is
exactly half of the fee max so say for
instance at this point velocity of the
enzyme reaction is just half the v-max
so if we extrapolate this point we would
end up getting km this is actually the
Michaelis Menten constant and now if we
would do we would try to look at in two
cases say for one case our substrate
concentration is fairly less than km at
this particular situation what happens v
0 would be v-max into s
my game as game is much much greater
than s so from our my Clinton equation
we can ignore these substance intrusion
and if we have our substrate
concentration if we have a velocity of
enzyme reaction that is actually half
the v-max then the substrate
concentration corresponding to this
particular scenario would be our km so
when V equal to v-max we would have half
V Max
km+ substrate this would cancel out and
then came be particularly proportional
to substrate concentration so km is
basically a substrate concentration at
which the velocity of enzyme reaction is
just the half of its maximal velocity so
this was all about the Michaelis Menten
equation and the derivation of the
Michaelis Menten equation I hope you
enjoyed this video please give it a
thumbs up and please subscribe thank you